[موسيقى]
نرحب بمشاهدين وبمستمعي مونتي كارلو
الدوليه كما نرحب بضيوف البرنامج الحاضرين
معنا ومعكم على الشاشه وتشاهدونهم حاليا
يمكنكم تتفاعلوا مع ما يقولون على صفحتنا
على فيسبوك او على صفحه البرنامج على
تويتر
للمره الاولى منذ ان بدات الحرب في
اوكرانيا اعترف الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين وقر بان العقوبات الدوليه اثرت سلبا
على الاقتصاد الروسي مع انه ظل يردد ان
روسيا تعاقلمت بشكل جيد مع العقوبات التي
فرضها الغرب هل يدل تبني هذا الموقف ان
ورقه الطاقه التي استخدمها ضد اوروبا
تحديدا لم تعطي اكلها الى اي حد يعكس هذا
الاعتراف مدى ارتباط موسكو بيبكين التي
الذي استفاد اقتصادها من تصدير النفط
والغاز الروسيين ثم لماذا طلب بوتين من
الاثرياء الروس منذ نهايه فبراير ان يضخوا
اموالهم الموجوده في الخارج فالاقتصاد
الوطني الروسي سعيد بان استضيف في هذا
البرنامج من القاهره احمد سيد احمد واباحث
في مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه سعيد ان يكون معنا من موسكو
اليكسون
السابق وسعيد ان يكون من لندن مصطفى
البزركان باحث في الاقتصاد السياسي اهلا
وسهلا بكم حتى نضع المشاهد في الصوره
نستمع الى مقاله الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين
قد يكونوا للعقوبه غير المشروعه المفروضه
على الاقتصاد الروسي تاثير سلبي عليه على
المدى المتوسط سنعمل على دعم الخيارات
الايجابيه الاقتصادنا
كيف يتوعد بايدن بمواصله العقوبات ضد
روسيا
مع دخولنا في العام الثاني من الغزو
الروسي العنيف وحدتنا لم تتزعزع سنواصل
الضغط على بوتين من خلال فرض العقوبات
التاريخيه
وسنواصل امداد اوكرانيا بالمعدات والدعم
الانساني اللازم للدفاع عن نفسها في
مواجهه العدوان الروسي
نستمع الى بوتين ويتحدث عن اهميه استبدال
الشركات الغربيه في روسيا
نظامنا المالي يجب ان يلعب دورا اكبر لدعم
متطلبات تصدير
نحن بحاجه لاستبدال المؤسسات الغربيه التي
تغادر بلدنا
وبما ان الخبر من روسيا نبدا من موسكو معك
الكسن ما الذي جعل بوتين يعترف بعد طول
هذه الفتره بان العقوبات اثرت على
الاقتصاد الروسي معنى استضفناك في حلقات
بعد الهجوم على اوكرانيا وكان طبعا هذا
غير وارد وان العقوبات لن تؤثر على روسيا
وان الاقتصاد الروسي في احسن احواله
يا سيدي العزيز هذا التصريح الاخير
وهناك ليس فقط هذا التصريخ جمله من
التصريخات ودائما يركز على شيء هو يريد
اليوم ان يشرح امام الجمهور او امام
الاقتصاديين
بالمناسبه معينه وهذا تصريح كان اصناعه
اللقاء بوتين مع
الحكومه مع الوزراء
موضوع يتعلق
بالمعض المتوسط يعني عندما يكون الاقتصاد
الروسي بخاجه
الى اليات التيكتولوجيه
لاستبدال الاليات القديمه الى الاليات
الجديده
او تشغيل الله انتاج المحلي
للانتاج
او منتجات
المستورده الغربيه
اما الموقف
رسمي موقف بوتين ورئيس الحكومه
الاخرين من
الاكوبات الغربيه لا لا يتغير هذا الموقف
خلال كل هذه الفتره
ليس فقط
بموضوع خلال فتره الاخيره
الحرب في اوكرانيا بل من قبل ذلك
ربما اهم من كل شيء انه الاقتصاد الروسي
بخاجع الى الاصلاحات لماذا لانه في
تسعينيات تم
تدمير للاقتصاد السوفييتي الله عندما كان
رئيسا رئيس جيلسون كان رئيس
الحكومه يلسون الاولى
برئاسه
الامريكيه
تدمير الاقتصاد السوفيتي التي كان اقتصادا
تم تدمير صناعاته اصبحت فعلا اصبح
الاقتصاد الروسي فقط مصدر
للمواد الخامه لتصدير المواد الخامه
اغلبيه الى اوروبا
وبوتين طبعا هو رفع موضوع السياده السياده
الاقتصاديه وهذا من زمان من صلوات ولكن
الله او الحرب في اوكرانيا ربما ساهم في
هذا المجال عشان اسرعها في اجراء هذه
الاصلاحات والعقوبات لعبت هذا دور ايضا
هذا يعتبر فرصه
ليل اولا انتاج انتاج زياده انتاج المخالي
زياده فعاليه
للاقتصاد الروسي
شيء اخر
[موسيقى]
تحويل
التعاون ميم اتجاه الغربي الى اتجاه
الشرقي هذه القصه ومعروفه
والله اهتمام اكثر
للانتاج
اكرر انه التصريخ هذا التركيز بوتين على
مخاطر هذا يعني فقط
للاكتمام الاكبر ميم قبله الحكومه
لاتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه
للتجاوز على خازج المخاطر مصطفى البزركان
لنتحدث الان الرهان يعني واضح ان رهان
روسيا على ان اوروبا اوروبا سترجف بردا في
فصل الشتاء وانها ستنقصه الطاقه هناك
استراتيجيه اوروبيه حاله دون ذلك والرهان
على الصين يبدو انه لم يكن صائبا الى هذا
الحد باعتبار ان الصين تشتري الغاز والنفط
باسعار اقل مما كان يشتريه الغرب من روسيا
تحياتي لكم ولضيوف الكرام
وللمشاهدات والمشاهدين بدايه لابد انه نضع
النقاط على الحروف العقوبات التي فرضت على
روسيا هي العقوبات الاشد في تاريخ العالم
لم يشهد العالم مثل هذه العقوبات كانت
مؤثره على الاقتصاد الروسي ولكن كان هناك
لا تداعيات على الاقتصاد الاوروبي وكان
هناك ورقه يمكن انه تلعبها روسيا بالحاجه
الى النفط والغاز ولكن ظهر انه
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه التي فرضت على
اوروبا وبالتالي اصبحت استراتيجيه اوروبيه
للتخلص من الاعتماد على النفط والغاز
اصبحت واقعا لا يمكن الخروج عليه ولذلك
شهدنا هذه الهبه من جانب روسيا ولكن هناك
نقطه لابد من ذكرها انه صحيح روسيا تمكنت
الى حد ما من مواجهه هذه العقوبات ولكن ما
هو الثمن روسيا دفع ثمن الباهضا من خلال
بيع النفط الغاز الغاز يباع باكثر من 25%
تخفيض الى الصين الصين كانت هي الرابح
الاكبر من ما يحصل في مواجهات عسكريه في
اوكرانيا النفط يباع بحدود 42 دولار في
حين انه
يباع ب 72 دولار هذه نقاط اساسيه صحيح
هناك اسواق قد يكون هذه الحاله هي دفعت
روسيا الى ايجاد اسواق بديله يعني على
سبيل المثال كان الغاز والنفط الروسي ياتي
من الشرق الى الغرب اليوم تحول من الغرب
الى الشرق ولذلك من خلال
الغاز انابيب يعني سايبيريا واحد واثنين
هناك ايضا خطوط لنقل النفط من خلال السفن
في المنطقه القطبيه وروسيا انتجت سفينتين
حديثتين للتخلص من
الجديد
لمسار هذه هذه الصادرات النفطيه هذه جعلت
انه هناك بوادر لتغيير الاسواق ولكن لا
يمكن القول انه الاقتصاد الروسي لم يتاثر
بالتاكيد تاثر كما هي حتى الاقتصاد العالم
تاثر بهذه النقطه ايضا طيب احمد سيد احمد
من القاهره كلام ضيفي من موسكو بان روسيا
غيرت الوجهه من الغرب الى الشرق هل هذا
حصل بالفعل على حساب الاقتصاد الروسي
تحياتي لك توفيق ولكل ضيوفك الكرام في
الواقع عندما نتكلم عن تاثير العقوبات على
روسيا تحديدا وهو بمنطق المؤشرات ما هو
حجم هذا التاثير ومؤشراته بمعنى هل اسر
سلبا على معدلات النمو الاقتصاد الروسي هل
اسرى سلبا على حجم الناتج الاجمالي القومي
هل اسرى سلبا من معيار الغرب انه اثنى
روسيا او رضعها في متعلق بها العمليه
العسكريه او تدخل العسكري في اوكرانيا هنا
التقويم متفاوت بالطبع روسيا حاولت ان
تصمت خلال هذا العام
واستطاعت على الاقل ان تقدم بدائل للصين
وهذه البدائل بالحقيقه يعني كما يقول ضيفك
في لندن جاءت بخساره على روسيا لان البديل
الصيني والهندي والاسيوي لم يكن او لم
يستطع ان يملا البديل الاوروبي لان اوروبا
قد تعتني بشكل كبير على الطاقه الروسيه
على مصادر الروسيه ايضا العقوبات التي
طالت النظام المالي واستبعاد
نظام المالي الروسي والمصارف من نظام سوفت
العالمي وايضا استهداف الطاقه كان لها
تاثير لكن علينا ان نعرف ان هذا التاثير
حقيقه والذي دفع بوتين الاعتراف به انه
جاء في المدى المتوسط والبعيد بمعنى انه
مع استمرار الحرب سيكون التاثير اكبر ربما
التاثير لم يظهر بشكل كبير للعقوبات على
الاقتصاد الروسي في العام الاول يعني ان
حجم الناتج للقومي تراجعت في الميه في حين
ان المتوقع او كان متوقعا بعد العقوبات
وعشر حزب من العقوبات الاشد كما اشاد ضيفك
ان يهبط الناتج المحلي الى 20% على الاقل
وبالتالي هذا لم يكن له تاثير كبير لكن
هناك تاثير بالفعل وهناك تاثر لان بالطبع
روسيا مرتبطه بالنظام المالي العالمي
مرتبطه الغربي معظم الشركات الغربيه خرجت
وهجرت من روسيا
ذهبت الى اوروبا لكن الشركات الصينيه لم
تملا هذا الفراغ رغم الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
الاخيره وزياره الرئيس الى الصين الى
روسيا لكن الصين لم تقدم حتى الان البديل
هذا الاعتبارات خاصه بالصين باعتبارات
خاصه بالركود الاقتصادي لان الصين متاثره
ايضا بالنمو العالمي وبالتالي هنا روسيا
في موقف صعب هي لن تتراجع مهما كانت
التكلفه الاقتصاديه وهو يحاول ان يظهر انه
لن يتاثر ومع ذلك ايضا هو استمرار في
العمليه العسكريه وفي التدخل العسكري
واستمرار الحرب سيزيد ويفاقم من الاثار
الاقتصاديه السلبيه على روسيا لان تاثير
النفط حقيقه يبدا من شهر فبراير الماضي
التاثير الفعلي صادرات النفط الروسيه الى
اوروبا التي تقريبا بدات تفك اعتمادها على
روسيا سيكون لها مردود ومن هنا كانت جاء
هذا الاعتراف من الرئيس بوتين بعد عام من
الحرب ليؤكد فعلا ان هو بين خيارين بين
خيار كلاهما مر اما ان يستمر في الحرب هذه
السياره سيدفع الى مزيد من العقوبات كما
ان حتى رجال الاعمال الروس لن يسعفوه في
الامر بسبب العقوبات الغربيه والعقوبات
على ما يسمى الطرف الثالث او العقوبات
الثانويه على الاطراف التي تتعامل مع
روسيا ايضا الصين حذره الصين حذره جدا في
التقارب مع روسيا الى تخشى او تخشى ان
تكون صدام مع الغرب بسبب هذا التعامل
الاقتصادي وبالتالي هنا الصين
التوجه والشرقا لن يسعف ولن يكون بديلا
لروسيا او يحل عن التوجه نحو الغرب
يمكن ان تتفاعل مع ضيفي من القاهره ويقول
بان الوضع
الروسي ليس بالوضع سهل
مضبوط
[موسيقى]
يجب ان نعترف بانه روسيا
ليست لديها خيار اخر اللي اجراءات اللي
نحن الان
وكما تحدثنا يحكي معك على الداخل انتاج
المحلي وتعاون مع الصين والعين ودول التي
تقبل التعاون مع روسيه لانه بكل بساطه انه
الحرب يخوض ضد روسيا الحرب في اوكرانيا
ولقد المقطوع مع الغرب ولم تعود في
المستقبل المنظور وربما الى الابد نحن لا
لن نتعاون مع بالفرنسيه نقول لا يجب ان
نقول ابدا الى الابد
[ضحك]
نحن الان نتصرف
لدينا اهداف واضحه انه بصله اعتماط على
القدرات الزيتيه هذا من خلال تسجيل القطاع
الخاص الصغير والمتوسط تاجيل
سداد القروض المصرفيه
وتعزيز النظام المصري
عفوا عفوا عفوا في النظام المصرفي انت
تابعت ايضا الكلمه في فبراير لبوتين عندما
وجه نداء للاثرياء كي يضخوا اموالهم في
الاقتصاد الروسي وانت لاحظت بشكل واضح ان
الاثريه الذين كانوا في فرنسا يعني لم
يضخوا اموالهم في روسيا وانما في دول اخرى
قبلت باستقبال هذه الاموال اذا وهذا اشكال
اخر يطرح على روسيا
لا هناك اشكالات عديده انه كما قلت عنه
[موسيقى]
يجب
نعتاماه هو موجود لدينا يعني بس الاموال
كثيره اموال الاوليجار كثيره
صحيح صحيح ولكن مثلا العمله نحن الان لسنا
بحاجه الى دولارات كتير
النظام المصرفي يعتمد على روبل وعلى
العملات الوطنيه
الصين
وربما الهند ربما بعض العملات الاخرى
هناك الاشياء الاساسيه متوفره لظيمه
مثلجات زراعيه يعني
ماكولات ولدينا طاقه هذا كل شيء موجود
فبالتالي انه بوتين ماذا قال انه اول شيء
يجب زياده الاستهلاك المحلي اذا صار في
هناك طلب محليه في
منتجات الروسيه فهذا الشيء يشجع الاقتصاد
الروسي
هذا
الشيء الثاني
من وين هذا صحيح انه فيكولوجيات الغربيه
ما فيش
في مكان اخر وهذا طبعا سيؤثر سلبيا وهذا
يقصد عندما يدفع عن تعصير السلبي بالمضى
المتواصل فلذلك يجب البحث عن البدائل من
خلال مجددا
من خلال
بس سؤال هل هل الاقتصاد الروسي استطاع ان
يعتمد على ذاته يعني بمعنى هل تم تنويع
هيكل
اغلب الاقتصاد الروسي واقتصاد ريعي يعتمد
على النفط بمنطقه التصنيع ومنطق القطاع
الخاص ودوره الانتاج هل هذه ستكفي فعلا له
مواجهه تاثير العقوبات على الاقل على
المدى المتوسط والطويل مع استمرار الحرب
نحن نحن الان بصراحه لا نعرف ذلك لانه
قالوا في الغرب ووزعموا عنه الاقتصاد روسي
سوف ينهار سريعا جدا وهذا لم يحصل ونحن
الان وسط الطريق
[موسيقى]
نحن لا نتحدث الان عن الغرب نحن نتحدث عن
الاتصال ضروسي انا ليس ليس بصدفه انا بضعت
حديثي من الاشاره الى تسعينيات هناك كانت
خيانه وكان هناك تدمير للاكتساب
لمصلحه الغرب
فلذلك طبعا مثلا تغيير النرجسي السياسي
غضب بسيط ولكن تغيير الاقتصاد هذا الشيء
صعب جدا ويطول
رؤساء وجامد
جار وسائل بعد
اثرت عليه الفودكا اكثر من اي شيء عفوا يا
سيدي انه عيسى كان هناك تغيير الكامل
للاقتصاد كامل الاقتصاد ما يسمى الاشتراكي
وصار فيه
يعني
اكتشافشيه
[موسيقى]
نظام المصرف في تابعه للغرب
هذا
ربما واحد يقول مستحيل تجاوز على هذا
التراث لاصبح التجربه اليوميه في كافه
المجالات
فلذلك مش موضوع عنه خلال ثلاث سنين خمس
سنوات
لم يستطيع لم يستطيع ولكن
المشكله المشكله الحقيقيه يا الكسندر
المشكله ليست فقط قدره روسيا على الصمود
امام العقوبات قد تصمت بس حجم الاقتصاد
الروسي لكن المشكله التكلفه الفرصه
البديله بمعنى روسيا وبوتين كان يطمح فان
تكون روسيا قوه عظمى اقتصاديه في النظام
الدولي هذه الحرب ستكون التكلفه كبيره
ربما تنجح مثل الاقتصاد الايراني واقتصاد
كوريا الشماليه اقتصاد العقوبات وتدعاء
تقاوم العقوبات لاكبر فتره ممكنه لكن في
المقابل روسيا ستخسر تكلفه ان تكون قوه
اقتصاديه عظمى تناطح الصين وامريكا كلها
مكان في النظام الدولي غير الخطوره كيف هل
ادركت روسيا هذا الامر طيب ناخذ راي مصطفى
البزركان اقتصاد العقوبات من تدرب اكثر
على الاقتصاد العقوبات روسيا ام الصف
المقابل
العقوبات روسيا استفادت من العقوبات التي
فرضت على حليفها ايران ايران لديها خبره
في العقوبات وتخطي العقوبات والاتفاق على
العقوبات ولذلك روسيا استفادت من هذه
التجربه فهي ليست تحت العقوبات خلال العام
الماضي هي لديها تجربه عميقه هذه نقطه
النقطه الثانيه حتى مبيعات
النفط روسيا استفادت من 500 سفينه لنقل
النقد الروسي بتخفيضات ولذلك هذه نقطه
اساسيه لديها خبره اصبحت هذه نقطه النقطه
الثانيه دعني اوضح نقطه انه عمليه البيع
بتخفيضات حتى قبل
اشباط الماضي او فبراير الماضي كان هناك
شركات ومؤسسات اوروبيه تشتري النقل والغاز
الروسي لماذا لانه هي ممكن تاخذ هذه هذا
الرزق او المقاطره لماذا لاسعار منخفضه
هذه نقطه مصطفى
الغريب هو الهند اشترت نفطا من روسيا
وبعته بسعر اغلى
لدول لدول اخرى وهذه الاشكال الاخر
ازيدك علما انه الهند اشترت اكثر من مليون
برميل يوميا من النفط الروسي كررته وباعته
الى
دول قسم منها مؤسسات وشركات اوروبيه
باسعار طبعا الاسعار كان كانت اسعار
مرتفعه وهذا الذي جعله اليوم ليست صادرات
النفط فقط الروسيه هناك صادرات بترو
كيمياويات تصل حتى للدول العربيه والدول
الخليجيه بعضها فلذلك يعني هناك هناك ردود
فعل على هذه العقوبات ولكن النقطه
الاساسيه وهي انه
الاستراتيجيه الغربيه لخنق الاقتصاد
وتدمير الاقتصاد الروسي موجوده زلزال
مستمره وليس هناك اي شيء في في الافق نرى
انه هناك امكانيه لانهاء هذه هذا التوجه
طيب الكسندرا عندما تتحدث تتحدث الى عن
استراتيجيه ربما ستستمر ان العلاقات ولكن
خنقه الاقتصاد
الروسي الذي يتحدث عنه مصطفى هذا سيزيد من
المشاكل الاقتصاديه في الداخل الروسي
لا لا يمكن ان نرى
الوعظه فقط من الزاويه الاقتصاديه هل هناك
موضوع امني هو قبل كل شيء
من الواضح انه ما يخصل ويحصل في اوكرانيا
وهذا جزء من المواجهه ما بين روسيا والغرب
غازي المواجهه التي بدات اظن انه بعض
نتيجه او في الوقت الغراف ناتو اعلى
بروجرام على
منذ ذلك الوقت هناك
بضع التحول من حاله كانه روسيه صديقه
لامريكا وامريكا صديق ليندا صديق ليلسن
والى اخره الله حتى يرسم ادرك انه لا
بيعتبروا عنه روسيه يجب ان تخلو مصالح
الغرب او حتى احسن اذا كان هناك تفاقم
روسيه مثل تفكك التي فلذلك الموضوع الامني
قبل الموضوع الاقتصادي الشيء الثاني
الدين الان
الخطه اقتصاديه اشرت اليها
الانتاج المحلي وتعاون مع الاسيا وبشرق
الاوسط والى اخره هذه خطه موجوده ربما
هذه الخطه لا تعطي كل الامكانيات اللي
كانت لدى الروسيه في حال الوجود ضمن
المجموعه الغربيه ولكن هذا ما يحصل ما فيش
اجمالا ما فيش لدينا مكان مناسب في العالم
الرياضه الغربي
تحدث حول الموضوع في سنه 2007 بكل الوضوء
انا روسيه لا تقبل قطب واحد ومن انطلاقا
من ذلك ممكن ان نقول انه كل هذه الفتره
كنا نحن نتقدم الى شيء ما والله طلبت في
نهايه المطاف روسيا طلبت
الناتو تراجع عن الحدود الروسيه
هذا هو الاهم يزبط بيننا طيب احمد تفضل
تفضل تفضل تفضل
تسمح لي
كريم من موسكو يؤكد انه كان هناك خطط
اقتصاديه لماذا لن تخطوها روسيا قبل الحرب
في اوكرانيا لماذا اخر ذلك ضيفكم يتكلم
منذ عام 91 بمعنى ثلاثين عاما ولا يزال
الاقتصاد اشتراكي يعني هذه نقطه الاساسيه
ويحمل الرؤساء السابقين المسؤوليه انا
اعتقد انه لابد من من توضيح انه كان هناك
تقصير في الجانب الاصلاح الاقتصادي
لا ننسى انه روسيا كانت حتى مجموعه السبع
اصبحت مجموعه الثمانيه ثم
دفعت خارجها وهي ايضا مجموعه العشرين وهي
ايضا مجموعه
هذه جميعها كان هناك فرص كثيره حينما كان
حتى العلاقات الامنيه كانت علاقات الامنيه
يعني خضراء وليست متوتره كما هي حاليا
لماذا لم تبادر روسيا باصلاح اقتصادها
واصلاح حتى العلاقات مع الدول الغربيه
اللي كان في الاتحاد السوفياتي يعتبر ابيض
اصبح في روسيا الجديده في بضاعه
اصوات والعكس صحيح هذا في كافه المجالات
في المجال السياسه الخارجيه
والاقتصاد
والخط اخلاق
يجولوجيا والى اخره يعني
تم تغيير كل شيء وهل نستطيع ان نعود الى
شيء معقول
المبني على
الامجاد الامبراطوريه روسيه والاتحاد
السوفيتي وروسيا في الوقت الراهن بعض
التدمير المقصود بقياده الامريكيه خلال
عده سنوات هذا صعب جدا
[موسيقى]
الفيلم مجال الاقتصادي عشان يفهم الناس
انه الجميع حتى الرجال اعمال الكبار اللي
في ظروف العاديه بقولوا انه والله نحن على
بيننا
مصالح الربا
لدينا
حقوق الله سوق الخره والى اخره اليوم واضح
لحتى لاهم انه هناك الحرب في كافه
المجالات وحتى ضدهم
ارفعهم في الوضع الصعب فبالتالي انه شيء
مبرر انه الان
يعتبر عقوبات والعرب فرصه
في الاصلاح الاقتصادي احمد سيد احمد طبعا
ندخل منطقه منطقه خطر في الايام المقبله
يقول البعض خاصه في الغرب
باعتبار ان روسيا هي التي ستتولى الرئاسه
الدوريه لمجلس الامن هل يمكن ان نرى في
مثل هذا الظرف وفي الشهر المقبل الشهر
الرابع من السنه نوع من الضغط من قبل
روسيا لن نمرر اي شيء في مجلس الامن ما لم
ترفع العقوبات هناك من يتحدث من
الاخصائيين بان روسيا ستستخدم هذا المنبر
حتى تحاول الضغط من جانبها على الغرب في
هذا المجال
نعم توفيق هذه نقطه مهمه جدا اصبتها انت
لان مجلس الامن منذ بدايه الازمه وله
متحده تم استبعادها بشكل كامل من الازمه
الروسيه الاوكرانيه حتى من العقوبات يعني
العقوبات هذه هي عقوبات غربيه امريكيه
انفراديه ليست ملزما كل الدول لم تصدر من
مجلس الامن الدولي وفقا للفصل السابع
وبالتالي تقوم ملزمه لكل الدول ومن ثم
تكون اكثر فاعليه على روسيا ولكن الذي جرى
ان هذه العقوبات كثير من الدول الافريقيا
اسيا الصين لم تلتزم بها وراعه مصالحها بل
حتى دول اوروبيه داخل النطاق الاوروبي لم
تلتزم في بعض العقوبات المتعلقه بالنفط
مثل شيك والمجر وغيرها وبالتالي هنا مجلس
الامن استخدم حقيقه كوسيله طبعا للصراع
السياسي بين الجانبين لان المجلس هو معطل
وهو مشلول وبالتالي رئاسه روسيا لمجلس
الامن لن تفيد كثيرا في ايه التسويات او
في اي ابتزاز لان كل الازمات المرتبطه
بكلا الطرفين روسيا من ناحيه وامريكا
والغرب من ناحيه يتم استبعاد مجلس الامن
فيها في سوريا في ليبيا في كثير من
الازمات حتى في ايران لكن المشكله هنا
حقيقه ان عندما نتكلم بالعقوبات الهدف من
العقوبات ماذا كان الهدف هو معاقبه روسيا
ورضعها عن تدخلها العسكري في اوكرانيا
باعتبار من وجهه نظر الغرب ان هذا انتهاك
للسياده وان تاكل المتحده واستخدام القوه
في العلاقات الدوليه هذه العقوبات هي اثرت
على روسيا لكنها لم تحقق الهدف الاساسي في
ردع روسيا او دافعها الى التراجع الى
الوراء وبالتالي
العقوبات قد تنجح في تحجيم روسيا فيما
يتعلق به نموها الاقتصادي وصعودها
الاقتصادي حتى ستعطل حتى مقاله الكسندر في
الاعتماد على الذات لان روسيا بالفعل
مرتبطه بالغرب متشابكه معها ويصعب
الانفصال او الفكاك عن هذا الغرب خاصه في
التكنولوجيا الحديثه اشباه الموصلات
الرقائق وغيرها لكن العقوبات من ناحيه
اخرى حتى الان لو بهذا الوتيره لان الغرب
استنفذ تقريبا بنك العقوبات وبالتالي لن
ترضع روسيا عن الرجوع عن العمليه العسكريه
او التدخل العسكري لان روسيا الرجوع سيكون
لها تكلفه باهظه ربما يكون ثمنه ثمن ايضا
يدفعه بوتين لانه هو ماضن في العمليه هذا
الجزء من الامر تكلفه كبيره دفعها ثمن
باهظ وبالتالي صعب ان يضحي بهذا الثمن او
ان يرى الداخليه العقوبات ويعالج الوضع
الاقتصادي هو الان لن علي ان يستمر حتى
يحقق اهدافه سيشكل مشكله في المقابل الغرب
سيستمر في استراتيجيه الاستنزاف استنزاف
الاقتصاد الروسي وبالتالي روسيا ستخرج من
الحرب ربما يعني كاقرب من يعني كمقول
الجثه الهامده ستاثر سلبا كبيرا ولم
تستطيع البدايه الاخرى الصين او الدول
الاخرى ان تعوض او ان تنعش او ان تقوي
الاقتصاد الروسي وبالتالي سيفوت الفرصه
على روسيا لان تكون دوله مهمه في مجموعه
المجموعه الكبار في النظام الاقتصادي
الدوري مصطفى البزركان حتى نتوجه قليلا
ونحاول ان نفهم اشياء ببساطه بعض
المسؤولين في الدول العربيه يقولون صراحه
حتى في بعض وسائل الاعلام لماذا يريد
الغرب ان يلزمنا بتطبيق عقوبات يريده
وفرضها على روسيا في حين ان اقتصادنا في
حاجه الى التعامل مع روسيا وخاصه فيما
يتعلق باستقبال السفن التي تحمل البضاعه
اذا هل هذا التصريح يمكن ان يكون بدايه
لنوع من القول كفى انتم تريدون فرض عقوبات
لكن نحن ايضا اقتصادنا مهدد
السؤال المشروع
بجانبين الجانب الاول الغرب والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه نجحت في فرض
استراتيجيته وتغيير
استراتيجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي لا ننسى انه
لحد قبل اربعه عشر شهرا كان الغاز الروسي
يصل الى المانيا لكل مليون وحده حراريه
باربع دولارات المانيا اشتريتها بسته
وثلاثين دولار بعد فرض العقوبات هذه
جميعها تجعل انه سؤال المشروع لماذا وكيف
ستفرض على الدول الاخرى التي لا تلتزم
بالعقوبات هذا ياخذنا الى الامم المتحده
ومجلس الامن وكما ذكرتم وضيوفكم الكرام
انا اعتقد انه سياتي الوقت الذي سيكون
هناك حد فاصل بين مصالح الغرب ومصالح
الدول الاخرى سواء في افريقيا في اسيا
مصالح الدول العربيه الدول الخليجيه لابد
انه يكون هناك وعي في هذا الاتجاه من اجل
انه لا تفوت الفرصه على الغرب صحيح الغرب
اوجد مصادر بديله للنفط والغاز ولكن اين
سيذهب
تذهب السياسه الروسيه هناك سياسه محاور
اعتقد انه انتهى هو المحور الاول في
العالم لابد ان تكون هناك سياسه محاور ومن
يلعب دور كبير في هذه النقطه هي الصين
الصين هي الرابعه الاكبر من كل هذه
العقوبات وهذه الحرب في اوكرانيا ولذلك
شهدنا هناك تحالفات بينيه هناك حتى بدات
بعض الدول يعني اليوم حينما تكون هناك
تصريحات انه التجاره البينيه بين بعض
الدول ستكون بالعملات المحليه وليست
بالدولار هذه نقطه اساسيه لابد من الاخذ
بها بمعنى لابد ان نتوصل الى نقطه ان هناك
نظام عالمي جديد نظام في 91 اطلق عليها
نظام سياسي عالمي جديد اليوم هو نظام مالي
نظام اقتصادي لنظام تحالفات جديده يشهدها
العالم وسننتظر لا تزال الصوره غير واضحه
وضبابيه وسننتظر حتى ماذا سيكون ردود فعل
الدول وخاصه روسيا على ذلك التوجه طيب
ارتباط الاقتصاد الروسي بالصين هل فيه نوع
من المجازفه من قبل روسيا نعم ام لا هل
يمكن ان تعول فقط على الصين وتتخلى عن
شركاتها التقليديه لان الصين تقريبا هي
المنفذ الوحيد حاليا خاصه بالنسبه للطاقه
منهم
شركاء تقليديين يعني
اكثريه في اوروبا الان اوروبا خارج
التعاون مع روسيه ربما سوف يعود البعض
منهم
هاري مثلا ولكن كذلك يحضر الروبي
غير غير وارد
الصين بالاتجاه
ويبال الهند والاخ
من من يقبل
ايران مثلا في شرق في العالم والعربي
الاكثريه الدول العربيه نحن نريد تطوير
ولاك معهم في افريقيا هناك القمم ولا
روسيه الافريقيه اللي حدث في 19
وسيعطس غازي الصنع امريكا اللاتينيه ايضا
نريد ولكن بعيد شوي
اجمالا ممكن نقول ان روسيا تريد الاستفاده
من كل الفرص المتاحه
والان مرحله انتكاليه هل استقرار ياتي او
خروج والفتن سوف تستمر ونحن لا نعرف ما هي
الاقسام لروسيا لا تريد ان تتكون قطب
ضخم
ما فيش لدينا القدره
ايزكام هناك كتب روسيا والصين وبعض دول
اخرى
بمعنى انه هناك شراكه متينه
والتفاهم حول
القضايا الاساسيه في العالم
وهناك عضو واضح هذا على علم الغربي اليوم
هو عضو ممكن يصبح منافس في
نهايه المطاف اليوم عدول
ونحن لا نرى ان نمصل اوروبا تتكون كتب
ومستقل اوروبا اليوم تابعه لامريكا
السياسيين عمليا بالكامل
اقتصاديا هناك ايضا اشياء فظيعه التي حدثت
في مجال الطاقه والى اخره طيب فلذلك نحن
الان نرى موسكران
معسكر الغربي بقياده امريكا ومؤسكر ممكن
نقول للصين وروسيا صين اقتصاديا الضخم
الروسي عسكريا وكذلك لدينا فكره لدينا نحن
اول من او في الصف الاول اللي قال انه لا
نقبل هيمنه الغربيه وعلى هذا الاساس لدينا
خلفاء وشركاء كتير في العالم ليس فقط
انظمه رسميه اذا تسمح لي اذا تسمح لي بس
اذا تسمعني
اريد اريد منكم اريد
حينما يكون هناك النفط في الميزانيات من
سبعين دولار وروسيا تبيع نفطها باربعين
دولار وهي تتمكن من ذلك ومستمر في ذلك هذا
لا اعتقد انه
سيستمر هذه بهذا المصطفى العلم العربي لا
ينظر فقط بعد اقتصادي العالم العربي
مصلحته في اقامه نظام دوله متعدد الاقطاب
في امريكا في روسيا في الصين هناك انفتاح
على الصين على روسيا الاسباب روسياسيه
اسباب استراتيجيه ليست فقط اسباب اقتصاديه
النقطه المهمه بس الكسندر ان لا يوجد
معسكر الشرقي بوتن نفسه نفى وقال انه لا
يوجد تحالف استراتيجي بين روسيا والصين
انما هو التعاون لان الصين تجارتها مع
الغرب تريليون دولار مع روسيا ما يقارب
190 مليون مليار دولار ولم تضحي بهذا
بالغرب من اجل عيون روسيا ولكن علم العرب
الان هو يحاول ان يستفيد من هذا التحول في
النظام الدولي هناك حاله سيوله وانتقال من
القطبيه القطبيه هناك شركات اقتصاديه
الايجابي وعدم الانضمام ضد معسكر او ضد
قطب ضد القطب الاخر اعطى هامش حقيقي
للعالم العربي لكي تزداد اهميه
الاستراتيجيه جاء الرئيس بايدن المنطقه
جاء الرئيس الصيني للمنطقه الكل يتنافس
على المنطقه واعتقد ان هذا سيعظم حقيقه من
الاهميه من وضع العالم العربي وهذا احد
النتائج اللي جايبيه ربما للحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه على خلاف التاثيرات السلبيه في
امن الغذاء القمح لكن على الاقل العالم
العربي الان اصبح لديه تموضع وسط هذا
الصراع الكبار واصبح له مهمه من خلال ان
يقيم علاقات متوازنه مع كل الاطراف
وبالتالي جاء بنتائج ايجابيه على المنطقه
العربيه
هناك اهتمام اكبر من قبل روسيا بالعالم
العربي
صحيح والان لدينا مع
هناك اهتمامات المختلفه بنسبه لمصلا سوريا
ومعروفه ونحن وقفنا الى الجانب النظام
الشرعي ولدينا مواقع
السياسيه
في غازيه المنطقه بين يزبط للخليج وانا
لست موافقا على انه هناك
انزعاج
الخليجي بسبب روسيا تبيع
باعشار منخفضه
بهاي الحاله يرفعوا على روسيا الا تبيع
على الاطلاق لانه نحن نبيع في ظروف
العقوبات ضدنا ويجب على دول الخليج
هناك صبر وصبر قد ينفع اصوات رفع اصوات ضد
السياسه العقوبات ضد سياسه الغربيه
اذا قالوا لروسيا عليكم تبيع النفر
التصرف معقول لا انا لا اتوقع مثل هذا
التصرف
لم اقل لم اقل لكن الصبر ربما
باسعار روسيا هي جزء من اوبك بلس هذه نقطه
دعني اوضح نقطه لمده دقيقه واحده الى
ضيفكم في في في القاهره انا اعتقد انه
الاقتصاد هو سيد الموقف الدول العربيه
الان بعض الدول تمر بمشكلات اقتصاديه
بالتاكيد ستؤثر على مواقفها جيوسياسيه
والسياسي وحتى القرارات الامنيه فلا يمكن
نكران انه المصالح الاقتصاديه هي الاساس
في كافه السياسات الموضوعه سواء في الدول
العربيه الدول الخليجيه وكافه الدول
العالم
الشكر في الختام من القاهره لاحمد سيد
احمد باحث بمركز الاهرام الدراسات
السياسيه شكرا موسكو
سابق وشكرا لندن لمصطفى البذره كان باحث
في الاقتصاد السياسيه شكرا لفريق البرنامج
امسيه مريحه للجميع
[موسيقى]